انضم الينا من مخيم جباليه بقطاع غزه
مراسل الجزيره انس الشريف انس اذا جباليه
هذا المخيم يشهد مجازر متكرره ونحن نتحدث
الان عن 100 شهيد ووم تحت الانقاض ما
الوضع
لديك نحن الان نتواجد في مكان هذه المجدره
الذي ارتكبها احتلال الليله في جباليه
البلد شمال قطاع غزه تم تشييع جثامين عدد
كبير من الشهداء قبل قليل هذا ما تم
اخراجهم لكن هناك مازال اعداد كبيره وضخمه
تحت ركام هذه المنازل بعد تدمير هذا الحي
السكني وهو مكتظ بالسكان والمنازل متلاصقه
ببعضها البعض في هذه المنطقه في شارع غزه
القديم في جباليا البلد طبعا لا يتوفر اي
امكانيات من اجل محاوله الوصول للمواطنين
تحت الركام الاهالي هنا يحاولون بايديهم
الوصول لعدد من المفقودين تحت المنازل هذه
المنطقه مكتظه بالسكان والمنازل ماهوله
هنا في هذه المنطقه طبعا لا يتوفر اي
امكانيات في المكان لا يتوفر ققم دفاع
مدني بسبب قصف قوات الاحتلال لجميع معدات
الدفاع المدني فيقومون الان الاهالي
بمحاوله النبش والبحث عن ذويهم وعن
اقاربهم تحت ركام هذه المنازل ا انس كما
بدات التساؤل معك هذا المخيم وهذه المنطقه
جباليه كانت قد شهدت مجازر عده واستهداف
عنيفه حدثنا عن كل ما جرى في الايام
السابقه في
جباليا طبعا منذ ايام القصف لم يتوقف
نهائيا على مخيم جباليه وعلى البلد وعلى
جميع المناطق في شمال قطاع غزه القصف
يتفاوت ساعات ايضا القصف المدفعي لم يتوقف
للحظه واحده على مستوى الشمال على مدار
الوقت القصف المدفعي ومدفعيه الاحتلال
تطلق القذائف في الشوارع وعلى منازل
المواطنين وعلى مراكز الاواء في كل مكان
ايضا كل من يحاول التحرك في عده مناطق مثل
منطقه الزعتر او منطقه مشروع بيت لاهيه
تقوم قناصه الاحتلال باطلاق النار عليه من
قبل قناصه الاحتلال او طائرات اكواك ططر
وايضا كان هناك عدد من الشهداء امس في عده
مناطق بسبب محاوله المواطنين الوصول
لمنازلهم فقامت مناط الاحتلال باطلاق
النار عليهم في منطقه الزعتر ومنطقه مشروع
بيت لايه الغارات حتى هذه اللحظه منذ
الصباح لم تتوقف والمجازر ايضا لم تتوقف
الاحتلال هنا يقوم باستهداف المنازل بشكل
مباشر وهي موله بالسكان طبعا نحن ن قبل
قليل كنا في تشييع جسامين الشهداء الذين
تم اخراجهم من تحت المنازل لكن هناك اعداد
كبيره ما زالت ايضا تحت المنازل جل
الشهداء من الاطفال والنساء كما وضحنا في
الصوره عدد الاطفال كبير جدا في هذا
الاستهداف ليله امس في جبال البلد انس
ايضا هناك 20 مصابا وفق الاحصائيه التي
اعلنها المدير العام لوزاره الصحه في هذه
المجزره في جباليه كيف تم التعامل معها
الحالات طبعا في شمال القطاع لا يتوفر اي
خدمات طبيه نهائيا او اي مكان لاستقبال
الاصابات سو نقطه نقطه طبيه وهي مركز
جبالي الطبي في جبالي البلد هذا المركز
البسيط وهو للاسعافات الاوليه من اجل
محاوله توفير ما يناسب للمصاب بشكل عاجل
لكن لا يتوفر اي عمليات لا يتوفر اي خدمات
حتى ي تطيع تستطيع الطواقم الطبيه انقاذ
حياه المصابين هناك مصابين تكون حالتهم
متوسطه
وطفيفة للسيطره على جباليا وبالتالي هناك
معارك تدور هناك ما اخر المستجدات
بخصوصها منذ الصباح هناك كانت اشتباكات
متواصله بين قوات الاحتلال والمقاومه
الفلسطينيه وكنا نسمع هذه الاصوات ونحن
نتواجد في مخيم جباليا بالتحديد في منطقه
تل الزعتر طبعا الاحتلال تراجع من عده
محاور في شمال القطاع تراجع من منطقه
مشروع بيت لاهيه تراجع من المناطق الغربيه
ايضا مخيم جبال لكن متواجد الان في منطقه
تل الزعتر وهي المنطقه الشرقيه الشماليه
لمخيم جباليا لكن ايضا تراجع من هذه
المحاور لكن ما زالت قناصه الاحتلال تحاول
السيطره بالنار على هذه المناطق وكل من
يحاول الوصول لهذه المناطق تقوم باطلاق
النار عليه هو تراجع باليات في هذه
المحاور لك لكن ما زال حتى اللحظه متمركز
في منطقه تل الزعتر وهناك شات منذ الصباح
في هذه المناطق نشكرك حتى اللحظه من
جباليه بقطاع غزه مراسل الجزيره انس
الشريف